Democratic presidential candidates are
back on the campaign trail today after
their latest debate ten candidates took
the stage last night in Atlanta
including the frontrunner Joe Biden
Elizabeth Warren Bernie Sanders and Pete
Budaj the latest CBS News battleground
tracker poll has Buddha judge surging in
Iowa where caucuses are now less than
three months away and with impeachment
in the headlines the candidates drew
contrasts between themselves and
President Trump on like previous debates
they focused less on sparring with each
other and stuck more to the issues but
there were some tense moments including
when Kamala Harris slammed Tulsi Gabbard
for criticizing the Democratic Party
it's unfortunate that we have someone on
this stage who is attempting to be the
Democratic nominee for president of the
United States who during the Obama
administration spent four years
full-time on Fox News criticizing
President Obama she cannot challenge the
substance of the argument that I'm
making the leadership and the change
that I'm seeking to bring in our foreign
policy which only makes me guess that
she will as president continue the
status quo joining us now to break down
last night's debate CBS News political
contributors Robby Mook and Terry
Sullivan Robby was Hillary Clinton's
2016 campaign manager and Terry was
Marco Rubio's 2016 campaign manager and
looking to your eyes and it was a long
day in politics into the evening we went
and were 74 days away from from Iowa the
first caucus so Terry
debate number five last night what stood
out you know I was pretty surprised I
thought we were just giving away free
health care I didn't realize we're
giving away homes too I mean I was
shocked by I mean the continued run to
the left in this in this Democratic
primary when they don't really need to I
don't think in order to engage President
Trump but they are giving away a lot so
former President Obama there was some
tape that came out recently of him
saying the party is running a risk if it
goes too far to the left that Americans
don't want revolution you think
revolution was still on the table last
night look I think revolution is fine
but just don't take it away from
everybody and give away free houses I
just I mean it seems like they take a
free house yeah I would too but I'd like
a boat house in general oh my god
Robbi we saw the the battleground
tracker poll in Iowa which is basically
it's like a 4-way tie but a big surge
for Buddha judge what is I mean this
that signal that the moderates are
looking for another candidate I think
you're gonna continue to see churn and
hesitation shall we say in the
electorate the number one driving issue
here for Democrats is they want a winner
they want someone they know who can go
in and defeat Donald Trump and I think
people are unsure look we saw this in
2004 when George W Bush was up for
re-election you know and we had
candidates kind of hovering and then
John Kerry came in at the last minute
and you know he rose up so honestly
until we get to January I think these
polls you know are just academic frankly
and you know we'll continue to evolve
but to that point you have Joe Biden
who's a top tier candidate but we
continue to see him make these sort of
gaffes and and have these imperfect
debates how does that affect his
standing even as we watch somebody he's
always had these guys I mean this is
nothing new I mean I don't think it
hurts him so this is one of those
situations where you know folks want to
want to hang on
oh goodness he said this or he he made
this mistake or is he too old look I
think the the issue that he's got is he
looks out of touch and it's not about a
gaffe it's it's about just being out of
touch in a policy stand but in terms of
a debate where you need to condense your
thoughts and speak in sound bites is he
doing it as well as the other candidates
on the stage absolutely not but you know
what Marco Rubio Charlie did the best of
any of the debates for for the
Republican primary in 2016 and we all
know how that ended yeah so we've got
still we've got Michael Bloomberg
lurking on the side where lines Robbie
sorry a Duvall Patrick who just jumped
in but they're not in the debate stage
can they actually play in this game if
they're not in the debates well these
are two very different candidates you
know time is the most precious resource
on a campaign and Deval Patrick doesn't
have a lot of time and I think it's me
really hard for him to put together the
resources to run a real campaign
Bloomberg on the other hand I mean this
man is worth almost 60 billion dollars
you know Hillary Clinton and Barack
Obama spent 1 billion dollars on their
respective general election campaigns so
he can get in whenever he wants and I
think he's gonna watch and see if who he
perceives to be a moderate candidate is
washed out and he needs to step in to
fill that role I think that's that's
what his strategy is Michael Bloomberg
has been watching to see what
it's totally in the water for what a
decade now I mean end of the day is the
only guy who's actually trying to go out
there spending money to get on ballots
in states and hasn't even announced yet
yeah
how do candidates do a good job of
balancing not being too focused on the
impeachment hearings but also talking to
voters about the issues and things that
affect them I was gonna say you heard
that on the stage last night you had
some candidates actually pushing back
and saying let's not talk about this you
know and and I think that's right
impeachment is out there people don't
need to fear more about it they all
agree they all agree that what Trump did
was wrong and criminal I think their
rights have focused on issues what do
you think yeah I mean look it's not and
it's not just that it's not gonna help
them in the Democrat primary but it's
also not gonna help them in a general
election with swing voters who are
undecided on it and if they and if the
things they need to say about
impeachment in a Democrat to win a
Democratic primary will turn off general
election swing voters aren't fully
decided on it all right Robby Mook and
Terry Sullivan thank you guys thank you
you're joining us